dan Senora was a senior advisor to the
romney-ryan presidential campaign in
2012 damn good morning gonna be with you
so help us understand the factions
within the White House arguing for a
different point view not only the
Secretary of State and the UN ambassador
well there's one camp which is the
second led by the Secretary of State
that believes that Isis should be the
sole focus and that nothing could good
can come from US trying to replace Assad
because it's not clear that the chaos
that would follow the fall of Assad
would be much better that there could be
a vacuum that bad actors could fill
who's in that faction well it's it's
primarily Tillison and met many people
believe Trump himself there are others
like nikki Haley who believed that we
cannot ultimately bring any resolution
to the region if we are not focused both
on Isis and defeating Assad because
Assad's attacks against the Sunnis are
creating recruits are provoking Isis
attacks
where's McMasters McMaster is trying to
synthesize the two I mean I think look I
think there's a general consensus among
all these factions that it's hard to
imagine a future quasi peaceful Syria
with Assad in charge that they all
basically agree on but I think Tillerson
believes we cannot do this we cannot be
the ones to remove Syria if other forces
remove so we cannot remove Assad if
other forces try to move Assad that's
fine I think McMaster and others are a
little more forward-leaning they think
that we could help facilitate a process
that could get rid of Assad what is
clear is that any way to deal with Assad
will have to involve Russia and the
Secretary of State is making the first
big high ranking visit to Moscow
tomorrow the question is will he meet
should he meet with President Putin
after yesterday calling them complicit
or incompetent yeah so look from my view
that the Tillison should get a meeting
with the President of Russia in fact in
previous administrations the Secretary
of State when they've arrived in Moscow
have gotten meetings with Putin but to
your point he's used very aggressive
language and that you know Russia may
want to make a statement here and just
keep it a Lavrov Tillison meeting
but what is most interesting to me here
is we were all led to believe that the
Trump administration was going to roll
over for this new relationship this new
grand bargain with Russia and what is
clear now is in a matter of weeks it
looks nothing like that
you have two additional elements I read
this morning that the Russians have said
that he is meeting with the Secretary of
State to emphasize that he's unlikely to
meet with President Putin secondly we
have the Russians and the Iranians now
threatening to respond with force right
because this is look that they believe
that the US action in Syria which was
limited keep in mind this was such a
limited operation this was basically an
operation that was on the Shelf during
the Obama administration that people
like secretary Kerry had been pushing
President Obama to pursue it was very
limited no Syrian officials were killed
there was not a direct attack on the
regime and that mere action is provoking
a lot of rhetoric yeah to that end that
airfield is now back open right what did
that strike accomplish I think at the
end of the day did two things one it
will make the Syrian regime think long
and hard about using that airfield or
anyhere airfield to you know exercise
machinery of chemical weapons attacks I
think they will think long and hard i I
think this could be a turning point in
that regard I do not think you see
current yes I think we yes because they
don't know how far he's going to go
there's about six or eight other
airfields like it in Syria and it is
very easy for the u.s. to systematically
take them out the US government has the
capacity to escalate the Syrians know
that the Russians know that and the
Iranians know that Donald Trump if
anything is unpredictable and it's they
don't play with fire here Nancy North
thank you could be with you guys